we didn't out what we fishery did it
online but uh oh yeah
Delia gets the D by a landslide yeah a
lot of people like why was it CEO on
there he was on the show this year yeah
he came on there but and also Thiel
asked us to take him off the voting just
so the fans know we didn't take him off
I was the only monitor just so he could
defend his but like he was not he well
he was like God will I was in ominous
you know man you and I do King this
thing so it's weird if he's like he was
running he goes I want to step away and
just you know I'm not gonna offend the
battle and step off yeah give it
somebody the opportunity how's it go I
had you on there just cuz you the
defending champions nothing to take me
off yeah cuz if he wanted to you know
turn it up you know you've made a video
or some [ __ ] or come on but Delia's
performance that the best out of all the
years is the best I've ever seen he's so
great thought that that Instagram I post
did you see that 14,000 you see it go to
my Instagram for a sec the the video we
posted was cool yeah right there right
there
watch out noxious this is just play this
this one yeah
hey bud sup brah how was your New Year's
Eve show at the whoop the Wilbur I heard
you sold it out there last minute
inching up to the laughs inching up to
Showtime right inching up to Showtime he
sold the last ticket was that hold
I think 1100 yeah was it 14 others he
was in Chicago you know what's a hold
that holds you know what I don't
remember
I remember now 3550 seats yeah
they felt pleased - I did too - uh New
Year's Eve that's it's mine and I did
two before that for that's 14th like
look at him the most punchable face in
the play he's just lying there all I
know at the end of his night
he's a funny scare in the world that's
so [ __ ] funny um I was the best
before and we left a voting up you know
and I it wasn't closed beeps I mean it
wasn't on my land I knew it Chris's
brother will tell you that since he was
a kid he lives to do one thing that's
make people laugh
that's what he likes to do he's the best
yeah he goes I go he goes well what'd I
do wrong what what my man dragged you
this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]